[Music]
they traveled from across the country to
the capital khartoum where the Accord
was signed many gathered at the newly
renamed Freedom Square once the site of
protest rallies against the former
President Omar al-bashir as Al Jazeera's
Heba Morgan reports from Khartoum the
deal paves the way for a civilian-led
government after 18 months of protests
and four months of negotiations Sudan's
ruling military junta and the opposition
coalition known as the forces of freedom
and change inked a final power-sharing
deal marking the start over thirty nine
month transitional period I stand before
you with pride after we have overcome
the stage of preparation and progressed
to the stage of construction we chant
together with honest hearts that the
focus now is on the nation a nation that
is proud of you and you Evette a country
that has produced people who have raised
its name with the generosity and
achievements the final agreement
includes a transitional period led for
the first 21 months by the military and
for the remaining 18 months by civilian
from the opposition coalition it also
includes members for an Executive
Council nominated by the FFC and they
will also have control of two-thirds of
the seats in the Legislative Assembly
but the coalition that has negotiated
the deal has other challenges some of
its own members have refused to
recognize the agreement saying it
doesn't address the core issues of
conflict in the country other members
say bringing peace will be one of the
top tasks of the transitional government
when the issue of war and peace is one
of the most important priorities of the
coalition and we worked to tie the issue
of peace to the issue of democratic
transformation because we believe in the
right to live in peace we believe in the
rights of the martyrs the displaced
people and refugees we affirmed that the
FFC aims for a comprehensive peace in
all areas of conflict
outside the hall people celebrated the
hope for a new phase in Sudan's history
but with cautious optimism the signing
of the agreement on Saturday may mark a
landmark on the road to a civilian rule
but many Sudanese say it's not the end
of the revolution they say the struggle
will have succeeded only when the
military hands over power and justice
and accountability begins more than 250
deaths have been recorded since the
start of the protests in December with
at least 120 killed in June when the
military raided the pro-democracy sit-in
at Army Headquarters which had become
the symbol of the revolution the next
step we are waiting for is the justice
for the blood of martyrs before power is
handed to the civilians and before the
economy improves justice for those who
sacrificed their lives so that the whole
country can be happy like they haven't
been for the past 30 years we don't
expect the road ahead to be easy but
hope to reach the end together the
things people lost their lives for the
demands must be met it's a first step
and that's what we're celebrating not
the end of our revolution on the day of
the signing hundreds arrived in the
capital from AD para where the protests
began in December before spreading
across the country the chants reflected
their optimism about Sudan's future but
also included a reminder to the new
transitional government that they're
ready to keep the flames of their
revolution burning till all their
demands are met Heba Morgan al Jazeera
Khartoum